oh look who we have in the building
sipping water at the same time it must
be in the genes we've got Christopher
Sims we've got Joshua pendrick we have
Adam left go and in front of us today
the big [ __ ] get over you guys curse
yeah why I don't know you know look on
the football field I'm I'm I was one of
the tops you were I was great where do
you think I learned it no you know when
I go and teach a bunch of kids you know
throw kids that throw the work with them
throwing the football I go uh will you
be offended if I curse and they most of
them say they all say it's okay but I
can tell some of them you know and I
have to be very careful really yeah I
love when you curse but you know we're
gonna get one out of the football field
brings it out I mean I grew up I saw you
on the whiffle ball field in July 4th
and it was coming out of here was it the
Sims family if there's any competition
it's coming out yeah well that's three
guys I did are you okay for that first
swing broke his back listen I went to
the gym today partially because I knew I
was gonna be around you to God you know
just a little cable action a lot of
lunges a lot of bench press yeah it
didn't work try though thanks bro you
need to come to eight one day on the
Parisi's I would love to kind of bridge
not just come let's just do I won't kill
you
listen I'm afraid of working out with
him
it's the truth charity I give away a
charity event work out with me I'll take
you to lunch this whole thing so this
guy buys it for a lot of money so he
comes we work out and I figure okay he's
here I'm uh I said what kind of shape
you and I think it was John John what
kind of shape I'm in pretty good shape
and I'm looking at him going man you
lying right in my face here I've but
okay so we go and do the workout so it's
over and you know he struggles a little
but it was a really horrendously tough
workout we're waiting for him at lunch
me and the guy that owns the place we're
waiting for an hour no we keep going
where is he where is he calling -
finally he shows up like 30 minutes
later and John where you been he goes
man I had to pull over inside a road I
thought I was gonna have a heart attack
and I went oh my gosh
so we did that many times man after that
we I've done in about five other times
and I'm like okay I'm terrible backed
off a little but the best one is boomer
and em get me with it
I had a group of women do it once with
me four of them and man they were all in
shape and they were just you did it
before why yes I know yes and then we go
so we go to lunch and I take them and
they're all in there and you know
they're like they're really like cursing
and is I said well okay what do y'all
want to drink I've been gonna drink you
know some a soda martini that it's nude
they were pounding it awesome did you
hear that we did a 50-yard challenge to
see if I could throw the ball 50 yards
no I did not hear that okay how far do
you think I could throw the ball Mandy
it was cold get on a scene well first
off did you get a running start yeah oh
yes that's wrong you gotta thought like
man stand there get your load up load
that big ass years on the toilet he did
he hitched up into it now the first
thing is enough he didn't use another
felt stinks in a windy field right okay
but in general how far do you think I
could throw back I would say if it was a
real NFL football normal I must say you
have 48 to 52 max I mean that's
incredibly through it 49 with that ball
that far then I don't know I got big-ass
hands you see that it might actually be
better I know a lot of people gonna
guess they can't throw for crap you know
the Jerry Rice of bleacher report well I
don't know about that more more athletic
when you came up to our house and we
played with Lesseps damn Adams got a
little something to like it was good
that's for you pops genes bro
but it's good but you know the de bet
would be can you throw it over handed
farther than I could throw it under him
I have that in my notes
do ya how far do you think you could
throw underhanded man I used to throw it
over 50 on a line I saw you do it on the
CBS pregame show yeah I was talking to
Travis County almost like I was worried
yet was gonna know some
I know they all said the people price it
hey man I'm not gonna hit the people in
front of me that's ridiculous you need
to understand that throwing the ball
underhand it is not something we
typically see well you know why I do it
because all the years I throw about
having two sons as quarterbacks oh my
god I got so sick of throwing the ball
back I started flipping and underhanded
and then I got really good at it really
I just feel like you've seen this
there's this whole generation of older
quarterbacks whether it's like like I
would see Steve Young dribble in the
basketball or Brett Favre it to be
spitting on his hands I felt like your
guys generation of quarterbacks had all
these tricks like it you slept with the
ball and now I see young quarterbacks
tonight I guess that's why we love
Patrick mahomes kind of doing like no
looks and stuff but yeah I feel like you
guys were like trickshot artists yeah
well look I don't know about that if I
knew then what I know now there'd be
damn statues built about me outside
giants Davis okay this means I know so
much more I just through everyday I
changed my grip yeah change my motion
kind of feel tight so I think I'll do
this I mean come on
think about how crazy that was I go into
the house one night and there's
Christopher and my son Matt and I walk
into the TV room and they're all there
laughing this wasn't you know I don't
know there's a few years ago five six
years ago
play on the 93 last game of the year get
the Cowboys because he's making up his
drop I mean one time it's the same play
he drops back normal the next time he
turns the other way but stops throws it
I mean there was no you know the people
didn't coach some of that stuff of that
and that's why Bill Walsh and Montana
were ahead of their time because
everything was always tied right work
when you run this play you take this
money drop is that reckless that the
quarterback could close off it into a
backpedal hey looks like NFL Street it
was yes bag peddling is a lost art that
they should bring back in the AFL is
you're a throwing cuz it just keeps you
loose and you can throw it oh what are
you gonna do can you throw it to your
right well let me show you here I feel
like Rodgers kind of does a little bit
when I teach kids to throw we do a lot
of backpedaling because they go oh that
was great I go yes and I threw I'm not
gonna tell you the kid's name played for
a major college this year just to show
you sometimes how cool
coaches can be yeah he knew that he came
up worked with us all some believe you
worked out Dwayne Haskins all summer
yeah I wish I wish I could but so this
kid you know we've worked on him so we
taught him how to backpedal and do it oh
this feels great yeah it kind of helps
you get in the right position all this
stuff so one day and practice right
before the season he back pedals in
practice seven steps hitches up and
throws a missile down the sideline in
the Carmel said the coaches name he goes
whoa whoa where'd that come from
did the sim stay though Sims has teach
you that he goes yes coach he goes it
look great man do it anytime you want
Wow how about that was great that's all
you want to hear you do what they ate
they'd look great if you want to do it
you just do it yeah and most coach to be
going oh we didn't like to drop its job
you didn't listen to your feet and take
the rhythm hitch you got to match your
eyes with your feet
quarterback gurus I want to talk about
New England because they just go get in
the pocket Tom and when he's [ __ ]
open throw it to them we don't give a
[ __ ] if you do a cartwheel or like
karaoke oh I loved it no I loved it with
Eli Manning had been McAdoo and you know
they changed the footwork hit so hard
and you know I'm listening to a game
it's all I keep Tom out you know now he
has to step with his left foot instead
of his right and you would you and of
course that's your boy yeah Jon Gruden
you know really and so the drastic
change in life oh my god and here's
what's great they're showing all these
tapes of what they want and it's aaron
rodgers you never do any of it right of
course i mean come on oh I've got to
think about my feet as I'm moving a step
or two what's funny as I was getting
ready to do the 50-yard throw and he's
telling me about my hips and then
someone mentions torque my mental launch
angle and I'm realizing this is what
happens when I try and golf everyone
just keeps saying another aspect that I
need to think about and then by the time
I start hitting it I'm [ __ ] cuz I'm
like oh I gotta worry about my eyes at
all by helps my back foot and then I
said you know what screw all these
people I'm chucking a ball right we're
just chucking a ball and that's how I'm
gonna approach golf from now on you know
what smack it I don't know you chucked
that ball 48 yards and it was a peewee
football so it's not
tell you to get your shoulder turn yes
yes yes don't be so you're gonna make
not you know it was like the other
people forget about your follow-through
I don't want to think about that you
can't you can't talk about the end
result the end result is its cause and
effect so true
think about the start and then the
result will come to what you want what
do you hate what do you think that's all
never lies it doesn't it doesn't lie
just like golf when you hit that big ol
slice of yours like oh yeah there's a
reason why I say no hanging fruits what
do you think about bleach report office
it's really unbelievable it is see the
whole thing yet yeah well I'll walk
through downstairs I mean here
everything yes remind you of like CBS
and all that stuff oh yeah CBS we're in
a building that's old it's different
it's been around the hallways
no it's not necessarily their office or
studios great yeah great studio building
it's not like yeah this building where I
mean I can me and boomer went to walk
down the hallway we couldn't fit really
yeah I mean come on he's got a big ass I
mean you know he's just a big ol each
report office there's nothing or huge
assets but we it's officially come out
the announcement we need to talk about
this before we get to the game what
announced MBC officially put it out
today what's going on with sim so why
don't we now tell everybody where you're
officially going by the way very very
sims move to announce on National
Signing Day to watch you this morning I
forgot that was Nationals oh yeah screw
you kids there's a new sheriff in town
forget that random forced are going to
Georgia right Sims well we don't have
any hats out here now I guess where are
you heading next III as you said I'm
going to NBC sports full-time again I'm
very excited about the opportunity a lot
of the things we do digitally here I
will do there but without you crying
emoji okay double cut emoji
I'm talking about I feel like a weight
has been one day show is going to be
reckless really yeah I mean as I've said
before bleacher report was the start the
beginning of everything I am they gave
me this launching pad to really further
my career
and continue to grow and and become what
I've become to this point which is still
a work in progress but I'm excited about
the opportunity at NBC you know Pro
Football Talk with Mike Florio I'll do
that four days a week you know you'll
still see me a Notre Dame stuff you'll
see me doing hit wait until Chris's of
the booth with Tirico right that's gonna
be awesome you think that's gonna happen
left go PR that's my prediction that's
your prediction I think you're too
talented thank you oh they're gonna be
like oh [ __ ] man this guy's really good
we got to put him on everything wait
wait wait
so dude and when I start calling Notre
Dame I'm just yeah be great I love here
you doing it you imagine Notre Dame fans
they revolt a Jewish guy that like is
off the handle I don't think they're
worried about that but you know listen
Notre Dame football is a it's the of its
own and you must be careful brothers
yeah I mean a I you I didn't I see Sims
there I think it's hilarious oh but I'm
asking you yeah do you want to call
games I don't love you know me I don't
love calling games I I don't mind it but
I like the open forum of this the radio
you know even pregame shows where you
just do a little bit more deep dive have
a little personality that way I wouldn't
be against it certainly not yeah you do
what they say
exactly and when do you officially start
I start it all gets unveiled that first
week of March
that's when the whole draft gonna be
doing all the draft stuff everything
that we did here gonna do everything
move it over perfect you know now
there's we showed him in here I'll come
every week you and I will just show
that's in part of my requests is I have
two big left go questions for you do you
want the really serious one first yeah
sure
okay the really a serious one is can I
still call you on Wednesdays oh yeah
okay and if Diane picks up I'm just
gonna talk to her if you're not there if
that's cool yeah that's fine - you don't
know if we're gonna let Wednesday's fly
no jurisdiction allowed to call his
house and then really make life annoying
for it was really a good day for this I
mix ups in the middle I've started my
preparation I need that little brims and
left oh man there's a lot of things my
kind of my other question is can I have
my wedding at your house when I
eventually propose yeah if you pay for
it you can help it you did and I'll give
you the house free that's awesome I know
you'll have a look I'm gonna have it at
your house I want a really really cool
band bringing in some cheap-ass band
you're gonna be there you're gonna be
the guy in front during the hors
d'oeuvres throwing underhand passes
don't catch it you got to do a shot so
you're getting married no I mean we're
not there yet I'm just locking it I
don't know if I'm gonna see him again I
want to lock it in I want to get Earth
Wind & Fire but I have a feeling it's
gonna cost me too much money is Earth
Wind and Fire are they from Hackensack
New Jersey I don't know that dude you
would if you had a run-in with Earth
Wind & Fire in the past I would blow my
brain yeah I didn't know I never have
there's a maybe it is a Earth Wind and
Fire somebody's from Hackensack a big
group kind of that style like Earth when
they fire it is I'm looking at up which
Olympic sports do we think it would be
funniest for Simms to cover so III cuz
if he's gonna NBC if you're there next
to the curling I'm gonna lose my crap
well curly would be great how about if
he's doing like summers like skiing if
he did the boat races the cocksman or
the for hey the greatest thing ever
remember Charlie Jones no oh you don't
remember Charlie Jones silver hair ain't
nobody listen this podcast remembers
charlie oh well listen Charlie Jones has
a man he did he votes cast for cocksman
or whatever it's called and he didn't
know the countries he goes the Green
Team is in front here comes the red team
and the blue team or the N is the blue
team from Russia he did a ton of
television I apologize yeah yeah he did
four o'clock game four years on NBC he
had and he was great he would
ooh advertising for his friends during
the game what do you mean
he'd go hey after the game don't forget
to go to Giorgos for Donna Boulevard
outings up and like Charlie what are you
talking about let me go Charlie if you
do one more commercial right your
friends and don't forget to jar the
Hacienda restaurant down any he would
just keep on doing he didn't care fire
sauce yeah it was great that's awesome
he was at the end of his career yeah I
remember him growing up though Hey
and then who took over for him and NBC
there that was that when Costas no it
wasn't Costas but it was I you know
whose it was
you know gosh dear all together name I
know they were there all together it was
kind of a neat group though yeah oh yeah
that four o'clock dick when you're
cranky don't cry Ricky that was I just
remember watching games he was great he
I'm hoping they don't use me for the
Olympics ever yeah it's the funny thing
is we know we know Christopher and it's
like alright where's like the next
Olympics
ochio Tokyo thinking about Chris on a
flight to Tokyo he's like I'm dreading
it left go like I can't do this like I
have a routine I watch film on Monday
when am I gonna watch film in Tokyo it's
a different time o Winter Olympics it
cuts into my draft preparation sorry I
brought some memorabilia from our Super
Bowl trip that I want to put up here
well I got Michael Vick to sign a copy
of Matt in 2004 which I believe is up
there with Bo Jackson is the greatest
video game character of all time yeah
right and then right behind that is Phil
Simms and the quarterback clubs in the
90s Oh O'Dell use I don't know if you
saw the video he dress up like a
crossing guard I have not I got him to
sign one of these little light stick
there was oh Dale cool
Odell was great I mean he was very aware
that Adam and I had stuck up for him a
lot throughout the years just a little
message to everybody there is truth to
love co PR I'm not gonna tell you how I
found out I'm just telling you that I'm
not crazy and that they may have
listened the left copia yeah they
certainly have listened and they were
cool I mean Odell you know he just I
don't know what else
say the mother was all his mother was
awesome he couldn't have been more
respectful and nice to everybody a
bleacher report on energy you know they
we dressed him up like a crossing guard
yeah yeah it was very cool but you know
I love him I know you do too why do do I
know the locker room loves the exam I
know that for a fact yes and you know
look I went on that show you know what
boomer many times and I said hey you
know they thought I said sign him and
two years ago I said don't go to
training camp dad you were the first one
really in that draft that really jumped
over Odell Beckham jr. where I was
hemming and hawing between him and Oh
Brendan cooks and who was the other one
that year Mike Evans and dad kept
slackens you left Watkins yeah dad kept
saying I don't know this Odell Beckham
jr. I think he's the one he's the guy
and of course he it didn't take long for
him to prove dad right well you know
because I know they're passing offense
was nothing but it's the way he can run
rounds yeah you could see it and I you
know of course some people had Jarvis
Landry way above him because Jarvis
block you mean the GM of the Oakland
Raider I don't know I don't care you
know he did how did you Oh cuz he blocks
you know it's like saying we're lions
with Jarvis now so you can't really say
I'm not talking about him good for him
yeah and he'd it's worked out great like
eighty million dollars what it's like
saying you know we can't draft Deion
Sanders only he's gonna tackle enough
like I can't he tackles Deion you have
permission to just dive to the sidelines
whenever you want as long as you shut
down this guy right on one right what's
he did I wish the Greek freak was better
at corner twos no you look incredible
right now he came to us on Friday and we
were doing interviews I don't think that
was charville injuries day but you had
just done your NFL 100 interview and you
were saying that you had been emotional
yeah and you know what I've been crying
enough right what the hell happened it
wasn't about him yeah you just it was
what are you doing to the NFL 100 's
just collecting people personalities to
tell their stories about what they
remember most about the NFL so they went
in on me about Super Bowl 21 that day
and yeah it was a 21 22 or 25 right
skews a special day in the Sims family
January 25th 1987 and I would have known
that but that's good and I kind of went
not that kind of memory I know it's
unbelievable I kind of went through that
stuff and yeah it did it got me
teary-eyed for sure what was it about it
I don't know I guess it was one of those
things where you know you don't I've
thought about it in my mind a whole lot
my whole life where'd you watch the game
but the 50-yard line about 30 Roza five
years old I was six and a half right
sign my first autograph that day wanders
on the game day thing and oddly enough
met the guy like 25 years later and he
came up to me he's like I'm the guy that
you signed the game did you know dad was
one day you're gonna be a big start to
his activity said and I won't like see
but did that whole thing and yeah just
you know as they started going down
memory lane I can remember sitting there
I can remember dad had to get 55 tickets
for the game that day he played for free
that where was the game Pasadena Rose
Bowl which is also special the best
place yeah I'm so lucky you had 55
tickets the entire state of Kentucky
come to the game I have there's eight of
us I didn't know you had 55 people that
like you well I don't I don't care I'd
like them either I know but you know
it's um there's we had eight kids in our
family
Wow so I remember calling my mom he's on
well how many do you think when it comes
she goes oh I babbles come Barbara and
I'm like oh really yeah Aunt Maggie and
isn't she went through her I was like oh
my gosh but you know what was great is
the mayor's were great right they knew I
had a big family and they quietly I
probably shouldn't other what's too long
now
yeah but they said do you need some
extras they said oh I do
how many do you need and I said how many
can you give me and know that they they
gave me like 15 or 20 extra tickets Wow
yeah and back to the marasmus yes yes I
they probably did it a lot of players
even when I was hurt ninety they wanted
to know if I wanted extra attention but
they what was I gonna say there are
people but is a oh yeah I know what we
went to the super
yeah and there was a the Denver Broncos
were really upset they were upset that
day I remember no they were upset before
the Super Bowl because they were running
into all of our teammates in the bars
and everywhere and they found out that
we got 25 they only got 15 per person
per person I remember after the game
Denver being upset that they felt like
there was way too many New Yorkers and
that too many tickets got a Giants game
I I don't know you know giant fans are
everywhere yeah you know so and I don't
differ a base but yeah it's New York it
was the way you say Super Bowl Super
Bowl Super Bowl it's so good wait so
what what got you emotional I just I
guess just the story of the day just
nothing more than that you know it
wasn't any specific moment just as I
started to talk about it I started the
oh no damn I'm like gonna fight back
tears about this left coast and look
yeah I didn't even die you know that day
was it's so crazy it's still really
vivid I can remember being in the end
zone after the game dad was already in
the locker room and doing whatever he
was doing but I could remember being on
the field having a catch with little
Jimmy Burt right and just running around
and think it was amazing I can still
remember seeing dad at the hotel it's
just crazy how special days I mean
whether whatever it is the day I lost my
spleen that could still tell you things
that are crazy just those crazy days
where it was a monumental thing in your
life it's so if I can remember every
little detail I can remember Lawrence
Taylor's kid TJ not having to take a pee
on the way to the Pro Bowl and the year
before and he had to take a pee on the
bus ride and his uncle on the spot did a
plastic bag and he peed in the plastic
bag just crazy crap like that I'll never
forget the other story that he told the
NFL 100 No so there were two story
you're right time let me Phil Simms
Super Bowl day yeah and the time John
Grune Jon Gruden ruined his honeymoon
yeah those are the no stories in history
the NSA I want to know about Gruden the
psycho yeah calling me on day 10 of my
honeymoon asking me if I was canoeing
back and where was I oh now that I
realize it's day 10 yeah
come back yeah yeah sure yeah let's be
honest after a week it's come on him for
it for like you know four months but you
know I don't even think it was day ten I
think it was about day eight he called
and then he called day 9 day 10 and day
11 great that's a great story I love it
you know you know what that I admire
Gordon for that yeah I do
of course you because he just he's
anxious you know and say hey come on
let's go yeah he was going crazy did you
did you realize as you were playing that
game that you didn't really have any
incompletions like could you now feel it
no no now you know I don't know I was
kind of uh what's the word for it I was
gonna go down in flames I didn't care
and you know I wish I'd played like that
all the time but I wasn't worried about
making a mistake and you know we had a
pretty good game plan I thought
everybody was wide open and I watch the
game years later when Tim they weren't
open that much we were making a lot of
tight throws yeah but it looked open
that day and and but I did you play like
that cool I was confident and we matched
up well all those things but you know my
son knows being a quarterback
sometimes I'd make a mistake girl in
game ago oh man now I gotta be really
careful and then other days I go I throw
an interception in the second series
that's on the bench everybody goes ok oh
my yeah I know it's ok don't worry about
me get your ass ready because I might
throw 6 so make a tackle you know in
those days when you're like that that's
when you play great usually you know do
you start feeling that when you wake up
unless you feel that on the bus do you
feel that in the locker room do you miss
accumulation of many things I read
stories leading up to the Super Bowl
well I read everything just like my son
does yeah but when Ron Jaworski played
against the Oakland Raiders yeah back to
80 and Joe Theismann in his second Super
Bowl or maybe its first two I don't know
right but they both made kind of the
same statement I couldn't focus and
settle down until you know the second
quarter and I said I remember reading it
going man if I were playing a Super Bowl
which I never thought I would my ass
isn't gonna miss the first quarter
that's all and it's all I always thought
Gough could have frickin read that well
you know and Parcells was great he was
great Leslie yeah I mean he's I always
assumed you and Parcells just yelled at
each other the whole time No
No you know game day he was always
pretty cool you know he said things to
me in 1984 my career is probably on the
line with the Giants and his definitely
was I was walking down the locker room
the first game of the year and say he's
playing the keyboard right there the
Eagles right two for four oh nine and
four touchdowns if I remember yeah just
guessing but I don't know and but I was
walking out and goes Sims and I look at
me goes if you don't throw at least two
interceptions you're not taking enough
chances let it go oh man was amazing and
really our whole thing was leading up to
the Super Bowl for two weeks he yelled
at me the first week because I didn't
practice the way he wanted but and then
by the end of the second week
everything's going great and he's going
damn maybe we should stop man you're hot
you're hot
he kind of goes now remember it's not a
game of perfection I said in our opening
of our Super Bowl this year yeah he goes
it's not a game of perfection
just go out there be aggressive and play
like I've always loved yes every company
should be like well but people in the
media judge everything like the game is
gonna be perfection and what is it
Christopher it's a game of nothing but
adversity and it's not a perfect ball no
but I think that every company should be
like that I think every company should
go do dope [ __ ] and if you mess up it's
okay because you're trying to make great
[ __ ] yeah that's what I think every
company but we can't we can't we don't
do NFL teams are the same way well you
know everybody is I mean if I had to
hear one more time for a coach I was
like oh my god let me sleep you know we
can't turn the ball over and we gotta
yeah oh okay well I said kneel kneel on
the ball every play yeah you won't lose
you'll never turn it over yeah and also
Rosewall greatest one of the great
throwing stadiums oh yeah great cuz the
field looks small it looks like it's 75
yards throws balls one of those fields
where you get on the field you go I
think I could throw it from goal line to
go line even though you know you can't
but it just looks that way it's like an
optical illusion is it the shape of the
field is the state field it's the
background how close the stadium is to
the field it's a little bit like it is
it's called pretty close like Green Bay
that's a lot like Green Bay in that all
green baby way Green Bay I never got to
play in the new Lambeau Field but it
must be and it's amazing just me being
there
I've been thrown but yeah it is it's
great are the fields that look longer
than they actually are
oh gosh I mean I feel like a lot of them
do look that way go what's the one you
think right away Cowboys Stadium
wait oh that was that was all I mean
come on there's no wind they got a hole
in the roof my god I couldn't wait to go
down and play the Cowboys warm no wind
yeah giant stadium was a freaking wind
tunnel every week I come jogging out
there in 20 mile an hour wind hits it go
oh here comes another mediocre day 13 to
10 win for your guys but you know the
old baseball stadiums
I'd go play the st. Louis Cardinals and
st. Louis right I thought we were in a
parking lot
yeah the stands were learning some spots
40 and 50 yards away when Oakland yeah I
didn't only played it you know I don't
know if I replayed it at Oakland LA it
was always it was LA but Philadelphia a
baseball stadium it was awful it was are
you hearing some of the rumors about
where the Raiders are gonna play next
year yeah no we're like the baseball
stadium maybe I'm here in the San
Francisco 40 or Cisco Giants baseball
stadium that would be great um I've
heard London that I'm saying that from
the start there's no way there's no way
where are they gonna go say get
organized in Oakland I don't let him do
it they've already said they will the
ice is still available I'd love prompt
to London season like in the NFL's like
timeout wait what you couldn't do that
to the West Coast team no of course not
but I just I love chaos right and then
I'm gonna go - I'm gonna go to bleacher
report I'm gonna say I'd like to live in
London for the year I'll be embedded
with this team hmm I'll be the only
American journalist in London I think
that's what my career should be yes as I
moved to London and I become the London
NFL guy we're the only people that give
a crap about European NFL fans so much
so here's left go yeah I'll tell you one
thing I'm not a beer drinker but when I
go to London - man you gotta kill order
it's my wife and I go in there and drink
a beer and I just go it's unbelievable
it may be that atmosphere and
everybody's in there after work in their
blue suit - blue tie and a white shirt
everybody and they they close streets
down after work
so you can have your beer outside in
like three what do you normally do I
gotta go me I don't I don't
oh there to London yeah it's it's really
great what what are you normally drink
yeah what's your normal drink well if I
do drink I drink one vodka one one do
you get anything else in it lime lemon
soda maybe a little but I I'm a
wandering guy do I ever drink more than
one of your I can't say no no come on a
spongebob that way
just water pants hey you know I like my
but let me tell you this I'm coming back
from the Super Bowl boomer esiason had a
plane so I bought a seat on the plane
because we wanted to get home yeah and
he had his radio show monday boy he went
and did the radio show on no sleep
that's a night I taped it and then first
I always like he popped a couple 5-hour
energies for sure cuz because I couldn't
see it but he's usually gonna sweat on
his Brown and he woke up a little bit
but I we had quite a few drinks on the
plane that say it was awesome cuz the
wheat his we can imagine insane like
that to the early mornings and you got
all that stuff during the day I got to
interview Saturday Hunter Renfro from
Clemson and Tim Brown at the same time
right and hunters ask him questions
about like the life he lived and all
that stuff I mean Tim Brown played 17
years yeah I'd be asking him - yeah and
Tim Brown's like honestly I've never had
a drink I've never smoked or anything
he's like I've never had a drink either
and I'm sitting there I was like I've
had enough drinks for both of you
combined thanks for doing that for us
man amazing Tim's a model model model
citizen yeah he really is he was one of
the one of the coolest teammates I
played with alright so are you ready to
get into the game so to to all the fans
out there what I normally do is I
normally take Sims as notes I synthesize
them and then I go here are the big
things we have one game it was the Super
Bowl we're just gonna go through all the
notes and we're gonna have fun and then
when anything comes up that's
interesting we'll talk I'm gonna give it
up to Phil Phil do you want to do Rams
offense Patriots defense first whatever
you want its offense Rams defense you
guys do your thing
let's start with the Patriots D versus
the Rams I mean that's that's that's
where it starts there's going to be a
theme here so we're gonna do one side of
the ball first
so Rams offense Patriots defense and the
theme is gonna go come on Jared that's
the tunnel Bank yes a little bit a
little bit and so you're amazed I can
even read sims's notes I am cuz he
writes him I'm Chris okay stop calling
me Sims to his sins okay I'm one oh I
call him Phil and I call you since he's
Christopher Christopher why do you call
him Christopher because I naming that
you dumbass alright by the way I would
like to get Philips signature yeah on a
ball sure I'm buying stock in your
grandson okay so when he makes it and
gets to the NFL right
I would like point zero five grandson of
the ball no yes and I'd like your other
grandson
the grandson you know Marie Kathleen he
can really throw in laser shots but you
know Patrick his father is not built
like a quarterback Yeah right I mean
you've got an ass the size of a horse oh
no you don't real it Patrick is going to
be Mike Trout that's what you don't
realize you're the wrong sport oh my god
amazing we went to the game remember
that yeah and he came out the dugout I
said what they linebacker
they weren't NFL running back I don't
know if they were lying back her legs
they might have been a nose tackle I
don't ever say kuanysh they were really
it was unbelievable they were special
alright so the first note for Rams
offense Patriots defense your own first
play a game as blatant ripping entree
flowers is this the new thing never call
a penalty now did that continue the
whole game or was there's little things
here and there you know I just still I'm
not a favor of like just things like
that you know again I don't understand
the playoffs and all of a sudden we go
here 17 weeks of how we Ref and then we
get to the playoffs and it's a
completely different game altogether
that's part of the problem with happened
in New Orleans and the Rams there
because that it's it's like culture
shock for the referees been throwing
flags all year long and now in the
playoffs they go don't don't in you know
don't get involved in the game too much
so that bothered me and I just saw I
mean girl he's running through a whole
tray Fowler sticks out his leg and trips
um they don't call it
you know just inconsistent like that and
without salt to also bother me and I
know we'll get it to the other side of
the ball but the stupid call and Nicole
Roby Coleman oh my brady throws a screen
to the running back and he's all over
and hit some and they give him 15 yards
or any defense receiver you know to me
there has to be something done there I
don't know what you want to say or what
you want to do I don't know what they
expected even so the defensive player
what they're telling me with those
causes he's supposed to stop let the guy
catch it gather himself and then make a
tackle okay that's realistic I'm pretty
sure he'll be able to do that so that's
[ __ ] yeah that's bothers the hell
out of it well you know get used to it I
know how y'all football has been the
same always and what do you do as a
player I remember doing a Super Bowl you
find the strike zone then you got to
learn to deal with it right that's what
it is so you have to identify it as
quickly are you trying to identify and I
think you find out you know the guys
that count linemen a defensive backs
people like that you know they know they
know pretty quick
what's and it's got to be usually
blatant for them to call it so I don't
have any listen the New Orleans Saints
play here's why that was not called
because they didn't see it yeah okay
just that's the end of the story right
they didn't see it yeah they whatever it
was they did not have their eyes in the
right spot so nobody saw nikhyl Roby
Coleman you know run into the receiver
they were late to it they were late
picking him up and you can't make a call
when you don't see it all right so one
thing I always love when we're covering
the Patriots defense is how does Bill
Belichick a matchup to start the game
right so go through it the first number
there is what JC Jack Jesse Jackson
Gerald Everett
so you see Jackson just like they did
Travis Kelce right same thing Stephon
Gilmore Brandon cooks and night Brandon
cooks your day was over it's over 31 is
who 31 Jonathan Jones there's a little
shifty underneath cordon cover Tyree
kill right there this week Adam cover
Robert Wood Robert woods right with
Jason McCourty on most third downs being
the other guy that mm a lot of their
third corners doubling well Jay I mean
Devon sorry Devon I'm s
and then Jason here would take on
Reynolds man-to-man in those situations
number 83 that's pretty much of an Asian
mashup so yes it is and what did that
tell you by seeing them they told me
that they basically just said this was
different than Tyree Killip oh he's so
amazing we have to put two guys on him
really what it was with Woods Woods is a
good player I'm not trying to say that
but I'm saying Woods was that he's
always the scheme guy for the Rams on
third down they're gonna put him in the
bunch and hopefully you lose them and do
that and New England wasn't gonna let
the scheme beat them so they said we'll
put somebody inside and ounces out of
you every time and if you want to run
those little scheme plays where woods
can read the coverage and go in or out
well there's gonna be somebody there for
him either way that's what I told me
more than not right Gilmore was awesome
I'd saw it live in a game watched it on
TV watch the tape he was tremendous and
just think what they went out there and
paid him all that money I thought wow I
don't know about that he struggled early
because he had to get used to New
England yes like wow you guys are a lot
of rules Buffalo newscasters were
putting videos of him like letting up
long touchdowns and he danced up a lot
of communication communication it wasn't
physical skill that's right probably
simplified it and said just cover this
guy for a big man and that worked out
well but here's what's amazing about
Bill Belichick and you kind of said yeah
I don't know if you quite agreed with it
but three games in a row three playoff
games they started a different secondary
in all three yeah now what other team
does that when they're starting
secondary I think well I'll be simple
it's a top three worse definitely at
worst that is the different one all
three games that to me is the most
underrated part of this Patriots season
is not only did they overnight become a
power running team that controlled games
on the ground they also out of nowhere
got a top three secondary when everyone
after losing Malcolm Butler and not
playing them in the Super Bowl and they
lost their other safety right Logan Ryan
left - and everybody said well this
secondaries going to [ __ ]
they they end up having one of the best
secondaries in the NFL those two
storylines overnight switch
that and I you know I get so frustrated
with everything why nobody was talking
about some of these matchups during the
week oh how you think Aaron Donald's
gonna do oh my god let's see what are
the painters do all they try to take
away best oh yeah I don't think they
have any idea what to do with Aaron
Donald it's because these played well
but I know yeah I know it's it but it's
just the same damn stupid talking points
and when you're into business give the
players a little respect talk about more
than just three guys if you want to get
technical this is gonna be me being a
media guy
it's a producer problem and the reason I
say that nobody knows who they are that
everyone assumes that viewers are dumb
also every producer only cares about
their show so when you go on their show
well what are we gonna talk about ruff
the top well we have to talk about Aaron
Donald we have to talk about the
quarterbacks and no one looks at their
shows as a connection but you guys have
to keep doing this the show's over and
over again but every producer goes on my
show I want to talk about Aaron Donald
okay well what are we gonna talk about
JC James you know what that's how I just
see the industry what you do is you take
it and you go ahead and get your
statements in yeah and you know why I
sit in my office every morning I'm
watching I'll stop listening to
everything on TV because it gets me
riled up and I just go and I hear I'm
talking about things I go that it's so
wrong that's driving me crazy it's good
to go against the grain well it's not
going against the grain it is the grain
earth they don't they're going against
the grain because they're they don't
know I don't know it's what I read it
and I'm just gonna it's my opinion oh
that's great that's what's taken off
this week but that's all I heard though
the Patriots the zone they don't oh well
you know this because we would do videos
where they'd say winner or loser or what
was the x-factor they need to narrow it
down but you're hearing zone and that's
not what it was in fact you wrote it
down right the next thing Rams tight
split definitely forced Pats into more
yes it did it certainly did but even
after I went back and watched the film
they said but still played more man than
I even gave them credit for in the game
in general and they just so let's just
stop this right here - cuz I've heard a
few people and dad and I talked about
this last night and the night before but
like domore shut Brandon cooks down like
I don't want everyone this is the other
thing what did you hear
that was opposite of that oh he got a
pretty good day he had eight for 120 he
had a oh he did he had a pretty good day
you mean the 45 yards he had with 20
seconds left in the game with a goal but
she was covering them right or do you
mean the 18 yard screen pass where he
had four guys clean out an area and he
ran straight man he tore Gilmore up
because that pretty good yeah huge
factor that adds now he's down for six
for 50s that's lie that's why I mean so
eight furred 120 that's great but in the
competitive part of the game Gilmore one
that I'm not trying to take a shot on
Cook's Gilmore special he's in the
conversation for the best cornerback in
football he was he had the best year of
any corner and flip yes hey honey is
this just the statistics back that up he
was top two and I saw and like I felt
like Rams he was like eight it was like
all these different workers but it was
Gilmore and I have to look up who the
other corner was but he was one or two
yeah you know all categories I know we
got all these stats and everything and
you know I I'm gonna be honest I
probably didn't look at him the whole
year maybe once I don't know I never did
mystics you guys use your eyes not by
the way the statistics back that's great
he's almost always and and you know and
I do every once awhile say so and so I
love what he's doing and some I'll tell
me Stan I go I don't care Yeah right
so you know and I don't you said it this
morning stats lie all the time and
football yes they lie lie lie but you
know but you can't tell people now
because we're in a new generation you
know well yeah my rule for statistics is
this I can literally find and I learned
it doing gambling I can find any trend
to make my point but the thing is
there's 40 different trends the key is
to look at all of the trends and all of
the statistics it's not just how many
yards do they let up after the catch
it's how many yards of separation and
when you factor all of those things
together then it gets accurate but I
could find one statistic for anything
yeah anything in the world now let's get
into golf yeah okay I'm gonna read all
of these into a row okay that didn't
make it sure second Drive of game golf
mrs. cooks on on post post deep cross
yeah this is same play he will miss
cooks on in the back of the end zone
later on what the f Goff
it's man-to-man with double on woods
because he is a scheme guy second drive
third down
what the f Goff first read to cooks on
an out route he is wide open play that
was the play yes he kind of brought him
off in motion he runs an out yeah he's
wide open for the first read and he
throws it gets a drive keeps the drive
going but instead he throws in a double
coverage Chung hits wood just as he
catch it incompletion because he wanted
the easy throw and one actually go third
drive her down Goff is gonna throw a
pick six to McCourty if it's not tipped
at the line of scrimmage and then triple
underline Goff is [ __ ] himself which
is interesting because that's what you
shut that's what you just said about
those other quarterbacks in the first
quarter yeah that it was it was a blur
it was all crazy right when you think of
like factor that was a good point that
what it was
I do think so I think he's going up
there and a little bit going it's the
Super Bowl it's New England they're
doing [ __ ] I didn't prepare for this and
all of a sudden you get a little bit of
like deer in the headlights of going
like damn I don't know I'd you know you
you I would think I never played in this
moment he's gonna be able to answer that
but just in a normal game where you just
go a little bit like damn I can't get a
feel for what's going on out here and
then you start to press and you miss
stupid easy things where you watch the
film the next day and go what the [ __ ]
was I doing I just throw the five-yard
out what am i doing still getting used
to you guys cursing so much but yeah you
know it it you know you can it can
happen hey Tom Brady first play his
first throw yes blatant first day of
training camp mistake right and he knew
it and he he threw it man I didn't
realize it went in over in out there but
he read the coverage wrong it was a
simple coverage he read it wrong but
with Jared golf he talked about the
McCourty he was standing there was gonna
make the interception so was the guy
covered him no mercy Jonathan Jones dr.
Jones is gonna intersect got it and they
both went like so they were the two both
guys so Jared golf was probably and you
said this a lot and and and look I know
it's tough he's a third-year guy okay I
know all that and he didn't make some
good throws but he probably there's no
question he predetermined
yeah too much is truly that is the death
of any quarterback because you never
know and you know we used to do it in
practice we would practice fill we're
gonna run this play now you know the the
receiver to your right is gonna be open
Laurel is gonna be open during practice
I'm like drop back and I throw it to him
and he's on triple coverage and they
look at me go
Reed don't predetermine you know they
would sabotage me on purpose yeah I just
go you dogs can you explain the feeling
of getting to the line of scrimmage and
looking at something that you've never
seen before is it fear panic is it I
just need to get through this play and
not turn the ball over
boy you're you're hoping this is where I
always go back like any good off its a
coordinator quarterback you want answers
answers to the test what are my answers
give me some answers to what I'm seeing
here now you know there were some plays
where he just was like damn I don't know
if I'm protected with this blitz when
they're doing this right now
I'm not sure what coverage it is so it
just adds to the confusion in your brain
and it can knock you off rhythm and
everything like that I would say the the
Patriots just a quick analogy they lined
up and moved you know the especially the
defensive secondaries a lot of movement
and positions and it had to be a little
confusing to him yes you know as you're
a veteran and I'll I talk about this all
the time if a corner is five yards all
for five and a half a red light goes off
on me I could see it right away ten
yards at the safety instead of 11 oh
yeah I mean so but so Jarrod Golf is
young so I could understand that
and the Patriots secondary is probably
one of the most confusing Hey so on
Showtime we had it miked yeah
and Sean McVeigh right before the game
yeah he said in coaching yeah he goes I
can't I'm really what do you say I'm
anxious or I can't wait to see how they
play us Yeah right
he thought he says I'm gonna Belichick
right about I just I'd respect how much
yeah before the game do all that right
but he's on the sidelines and the game
is getting ready start man I can't wait
to see how they're gonna play us because
he knew it's gonna be a whole different
thing yeah they were gonna do different
what they'd show done right after the
fourth drive you wrote Goff hasn't
thrown a spiral yet
so he doesn't know if he's being
protected or not he is used to McVeigh
saving him yeah and this was a theme
that you had in the rest of the notes
that you kept saying like you said this
right here tight splits make it a phone
booth game and the Patriots are bigger
they they are gonna win that game when
they spread it out you can see they have
a better chance and it's easier on golf
double star here third two and three
Pat's playing past every time golf can't
get off the first read no your Notes
kept going back to gothis used to this
offense having the answers forehead
right and in this game the Patriots said
that answer sheet doesn't fit no it's
not Goff wasn't able to do it himself
you actually made it seem like McVeigh
was has helped him too much in the play
I think he's a little bit spoiled for
lack of a better phrase than that like
we've talked about before there's too
many silver platter plays for Jared
golf's career like here you go with all
you got to do is drop back in there's
gonna be somebody open for 20 yards it's
all yours if you can just hit a side of
the wall and yes but I do think it
became a little detriment in the in this
two things I gotta get to first off the
play we talked about the play that
everybody knows about in the back of the
end zone where Brandon cooks yes all
right that play was run earlier in the
football game we got to talk about them
it's the same coverage same exact play
two different times
both times Jared golf wants to throw the
deep crosser to Robert woods why why
does he want to throw to him cuz it's
been open all year long off the play
action and he's going every time I've
done this all year I've thrown to Robert
woods and it's 25 years at 25 yards like
crease lacrosse yeah exactly right but
now the play is intent intended to be
run it's as basic mad and crap go
anybody that plays on mat it's a deep
post with a deep crosser your first read
is always supposed to be look at the
deep post even if you know it's a look
right where the Safety's deep and he's
not throw one of the crosses oh look at
him yeah force the coverage and for the
timing and rhythm of the play to then
okay now I'm ready for the guy to come
across and it looks normal so he's
looking at his second read first cuz
it's been in this place always there and
what's troubling to me is it was
quarters coverage so it was four it's
four across everybody out there that
knows some we've explained it a lot on
this podcast everybody
got there their quarter of the field but
in quarters coverage the safeties have
the ability to sit flat-footed they are
not necessarily worried about what's
behind them that's on the corners
actually and that's why you see McCourty
come over and save it in the back of the
end zone but quarters right off the bat
and the West Coast system is alert post
every time when you see quarters it is
alert to the post because the safeties
are gonna be flat-footed and they can
take away crossers and they're there for
a little bit of rice you're crossing
over from one quarter to another which
is a press in the communication between
exam so the safety see woods coming and
they're going way he's coming into my
quarter he's writing into my quarter
we're gonna stop him we've seen this
place so much times and there's the
cooks and the first time he had it he
should have thrown it and he threw an
incompletion into like double or triple
coverage on the post Gilmore was on the
outside edge scopes got an inside
release and it's there to be had then of
course they go man look what was open it
was there again and he makes the same
mistake same coverage they disguised
that a little different looked like it
was gonna be single safety three deep at
the snap of the ball the backside safety
moved back they got equal and four
across the difference between the one in
the end zone with cooks is Gilmore who
had saw the play 55 million freakin
times through the week goes out here
comes woods yes I'm gonna get a pic and
he left him and I luckily McCourty on
the backside man who's supposed to be
there for that right recognized it in
time to get there and break unbelievable
right it really was it's it's crazy when
you think a Super Bowl can come down to
one right yes yeah and I think to you
know not and it's you know Jared golf
did like I said make some good throws
but he had time on that throw and if he
just christopher already said it if he
just striped it it's gonna get there
more McCord again gets the strike he
just it just didn't you know which
happens he's got he's got a big motion
so that motion you know a lot has to
connect Shore and when it does it
connect right it's gonna be a little
different sure and you know I talked
about that in a pregame I actually
showed all that stuff and I said I think
as time goes along you know you learn as
a quarterback you start changing your
motion yeah he's gonna have to fix his a
little cuz you're looking for perfection
you know you want you
you've got to have that [ __ ] look you
can never drop back and have success if
you're worried about where the balls
gonna go now I had it my career
something you know games where it's
windy the ball it's hard to be a good
decision maker when you worry about
where it's gonna go
you can't even have to think about it no
you gotta just reacts you gotta be man
you just you just kind of throw it
exactly where you want it to go is it to
this point yeah the NFC Championship
game he came out okay and I know it
threw some incompletions early every
ball he threw was a spiral everyone even
the come in completions in the NFC
Championship game from the get-go and
Super Bowl 53 every ball was a wobbler
and there really wasn't I don't think
very many spirals the whole game if you
would have told Rams fans and Eagles
fans three years ago that your young
quarterback taken 1 & 2 both will go to
the Super Bowl one of your teams is
gonna win it and they're both gonna be
under the age of 26 you go holy crap but
I look at whence and I look at goth and
all I have are questions right now are
the Rams really gonna make him one of
the highest-paid quarterbacks because
looking at his statistics and looking at
what he's accomplished it's gonna fill
the criteria but I'm sitting here
reading these notes and haven't watched
that game going I can't pay him well you
know million 30 million dollars a year
and then I look at whence and it's all
these questions about the team and how
they do with foals it's just fascinating
to me that 3 years ago if we would have
known this would happen we go back up
the Brinks truck but right now I have
questions for both yeah I don't I don't
have questions for Wednesday I don't
have any questions for Wednesday but he
plays yeah yeah and Jared golf you know
listen things will change in Los Angeles
we've talked about this I don't know if
we today you know Shawn McVeigh is gonna
change they're gonna do more with their
offense and all this other stuff and and
he's gonna get better
seanix a big face good he's got another
year to really solidify himself as the
guy that he's gonna be connected to
McVeigh for McVeigh's career in right
yes I'm with you I'm not panicked about
Jared Goff okay it was an ugly game I
understand all the questions yeah Jared
golf and to me we'll never I don't think
he's
ever going to be the the first pick of
the draft he can take over the game at
any moment right like we've seen other
top quarterbacks do super high execute
he made huge throws in the NFC
Championship game where they don't win
that game unless Jared Goff made a few
of the plays Nate played incredible in
that incredible game against the Chiefs
earlier this year I showed up in big
moment he ever played well in the state
and then the Saints came yeah agreed he
had moments this year where I said Tim
okay those weren't silver platter plays
he made some plays on his own with his
ability everything fell apart a little
for the Rams offense towards the end of
the it did that's really where it starts
they got lucky against the Cowboys
because they found a scheme that they
exposed life was tough with the New
Orleans Rams they made a few plays and
then kryptonite came to town for Super
Bowl 53 and that was the logic Bill
Belichick and the Big M effers they got
up front
you wrote 71 93 and 94 play all playoff
round don't tell me Brown Butler of
course in 71
no no 70s butler come on it's a big guy
I know he's from uh they got him out oh
come on yeah I just talked about Shelton
Shelton yeah and he was there was no
concussion protocol on your day so we
get it was 993 is Lauren Scott was a
base dominated the game the issues that
we had with the interior right 66 and 65
Blythe they struggled it was struggle
and they got overpowered what we saw
with them basically at the end of the
year was when they played teams like the
Eagles the Bears the Patriots and well
that's a great analogy rear D lineman
that had big could to gap can move you
they really struggled and not from this
size size
Danny Shelton is big but it's really an
interior pass rusher right Toby he's got
big feet no he's got good feet great but
I know he's got a big ol you know but
well he's got that it's not like even a
big pretty body I don't know but as he
he made some great moves getting around
the off I think he was playing against
Sullivan one or two times he almost went
around him and didn't get touched yeah
you said Hightower was a baller to
Hightower was a baller throughout the
playoffs
Hightower's
oddly enough his biggest key or success
he has it's been a pass rusher of the
whole playoffs
really his size and just talking about
laps jackets and do that is phenomenal
and and and you know dr. Hart our as dad
would tell you and he can verify this
the TV just doesn't do justice for how
big the human is his head is three times
bigger than any of ours here he's a huge
man and him running into offensive
tackles and overpowering and people
probably see it not only that yeah he's
great inside he sets some pics in yes
he's great at that that was really good
I'm a New England and towards the end of
the year just to show you how they
adapted you talked about they changed
the running game towards the end of the
year they became a more I thought they
started blitzing more and they're
blitzes they were not good they were
great yeah and and if we went and did a
real statistical look at maybe I'm gonna
say the last five weeks of the year I
have a hard time remembering a
completion against their blitzes right I
mean none it's phenomenal and I mean
guys came free every time and of course
you talked about Dante Hightower yeah to
me you're right he's a huge human but he
looked like he's dropped a little weight
and man can he run again with that size
and running and all that
I thought his career was never gonna
live up to what it was gonna be because
of injury right but this year now he's
got a few rings yeah man he played great
before you got to flip it to the other
side well I was just gonna say talk
about the six one and what they did
there I know we said it a little on
Monday but that was that was phenomenal
and how they did New England did some
things they didn't play their bare front
up front all game like they usually do
against these type of teams they ran
more of a true four down alignment right
yes and then they put Vannoy a week and
Chun strong over the tight end so if
they wanted to play man he could go
upside down if they wanted to play cover
three that was great but what it did
that's different from New England is the
inside guys definitely more more
aggressive getting up field they to gap
some to which is social side guys had no
worries they were able to oh you want to
run inside zone we're gonna collapse it
or we're just gonna attack them defense
every game well they will but doesn't
leave you open they don't play it's a
different game right
exactly right that's it so there you go
wait what did we just say so New England
yes well yeah that's their flexibility
their knowledge their grasp of the game
they on both sides of the ball
determined the game is gonna their game
plan is gonna be determined on who
they're playing and how many teams in
the NFL can do that now and that's the
personal fear I flipped to those side
because the rest of notes there we
talked about the back in the end zone
Gilmore dominated Kooks here you is go
is this is Super Bowl number eight right
for your former coach Bill Belichick to
is a DC with you guys and then six is
the head coach of the Patriots and every
year he never wins coach of the year and
every year he does a performance like
this where he takes an all-time great
offense and reduces them to three total
my Super Bowl eight he's got eight he's
got two as a defensive coordinator with
the giant not only has nine as a head
coach with the Patriots the numbers get
too long okay but he goes out there and
it's not even shocking anymore people
are now getting excited to go we get to
watch bill diagnose how to stop
McVeigh's I thought this was this was
the cream this was his best soup to me I
thought the coaching he should have one
coach of the year this year why can't
everybody it's yeah but he came late but
I just think that we we kind of accept
it or whatever what they do so that's
why I didn't get the acclaim you just
want to know what you like did you ever
see any of this when he was there well I
saw the work I saw all the teaching the
just the hammering and relentlessness of
him just going over the simplest thing I
would have to do a game when they were
doing playing the Denver Broncos with
Tim Tebow and I forgot the outside it
was ninka [ __ ] yeah was the outside
linebacker so they're worried about TV
reads and the zone read oh you can't
stop his own read you know as
quarterback come run they don't have an
eighth guy oh yeah okay how that theory
work out for all you commentators out
there a little shot at a few people but
ninka vets didn't put his left hand on
the left shoulder of the tackle and they
ran this play like four times about do
it again and I'm thinking oh my god get
your damn
hand and he went over and over it and it
was that explained everything to me and
I went up there I did 90 games of the
Patriots over the years you really yeah
I think it was high 80s maybe 90 I don't
know whatever I lost count but when I
would watch them practice on Friday it
was if I saw 250 practices all their
practices would probably be all the top
ones there Friday practices were
unbelievable they were competitive
they went over everything they were
allowed they were coaching the players
were you know really into it yelling at
each other all this stuff it was it was
really incredible there's a there's a
clip going around today of Belichick in
the middle of the game I don't know when
it was but he's on the headset and he's
going Josh Josh where's McVeigh I don't
see McGee I don't have eyes on him yeah
and then he's like oh +40 okay I got him
would alert E or +30 what's he look like
what does he want to see from McVeigh
Annette well Chris I might know more to
me
he wants to watch McVeigh because I'm
sure they watch TV tapes or something I
had a tip and he just wants to see who
he's talking to
what's going on you know the
communication who's coming I'm talking
to him all those things are just trying
to get a hint of what he's gonna do to
your breathing so I would agree it's
some sort of tell I would think that L
would be this oh I would think that L
would be this just and I don't know this
is next level he's watching the
sidelines not watching the coach he
watches TV film what's to tell
I think that he's probably the tell I
bet you when he saw plays be done and on
TV as soon as McVeigh put his thing up
he meant oh they're gonna hurry up to
the line and go fast and if they didn't
then do that then maybe they were gonna
actually go in the huddle and do that
that would be the first thing I thought
I saw it right you know as soon as he
goes oh it's a completion let's let's
hurry up hurry up Jarrod get to get to
the play get to the play
we're gonna run West right slot 72 Z
bigger you sweat hurry hurry hurry he
just that I bet you they were then going
they're gonna run something quick we
can't substitute get the call in blah
blah blah I would imagine it's little
things like that such a cool moment cuz
he was like all right I got him plus
there plus there's a lot of there were a
lot of cool moments in it and all the
video that came out from the NFL he gets
his coaches together goes look we got 12
plays yeah be organized dough it out
yeah get you know get the call in there
get the right
shanell 12 plays that's all we got left
you know it was like and then he dinner
with the players too he sat all the
players down he was like don't screw it
up we've won the Super Bowl as long as
you don't make a mistake it was great
like this he goes look we're winning the
battle word vertical I know we're not
but we're disrupting we got him covered
all this don't make a mistake they can't
beat us I think I was is that what he
said yes they can't win he no I and you
said that during the game I would say
this that they should rename the
Lombardy the Belichick not yet but I
don't but I don't know if you ever can
yeah but what can they give him that
that warrants what he's accomplished
well you don't it's funny I I'm always
big into this stuff like who's changed
football buddy rhyme with his 4065 Bill
Walsh with his offense Vince Lombardi
but who started by learning how to teach
and change rules along the same play but
it changes the rules because this
defense lines up like this and like this
instead of calling a new play insulin
party just taught well this is our play
and if they line up like this we broke
it like this if they line up like that
we block it like make calls started so
he did that with film breakdown so I
could just didn't realize that most of
those cigarettes and smash them in there
cuz you ever see the documentary on him
yeah I mean I mean there's nothing
cooler than a broken cigarette I could
tell somebody was like you gotta block
that guy Johnny
so another guy that you know changed
football's Lawrence Taylor
he changed past protections and how you
do it with linebackers that was
different today Bill Belichick eight
Manning with his hurry up offense he's
and all the things that changed football
or did he perfect it well I would put
him in all set there I'm putting him in
all those categories because he's doings
he innovated something that nobody that
that all coaches I think Christopher got
start being like this man right because
you can't just say well this is our
system you know which all these teams do
well this is what we do we're just gonna
be who we are
well do what our city know you've got to
be more complicated in Mobile multiple
now yeah because the athletes and it you
gotta find advantages for your players
if I said to you who really truly had
the more talented team on Sunday it
would be close
cuz doing those defensive lines
underrate it is but I still would have
gave it to the Rams yes
yeah the Rams yeah you know so the
Patriots for all the greatness we're
talking about we're talking about one or
two Mis throws that could have turned it
all around
yeah right right okay see you brought a
note with what looks to be child
handwriting yeah and one of your well
what did you worry about Dee Ford there
I wrote deep for just think if he
doesn't line up offsides how history has
changed or in the neutral zone because
the Patriots are gonna lose then Kansas
City's in the Super Bowl we don't know
who wins but I know this right Jarrod
golf would have thrown for a lot of
yards yeah and we would be viewing him
completely different in cement I mean
that that basic thoughts my phil simms
yeah very correct but here's another one
i an't listen I'm not saying Julian
Edelman shouldn't when you watch the
game yeah every play in every catch I
give him a lot of crew but it was all
creative for it set up for success
really gotta throw the ball to they're
gonna throw either the Grunk or Julian
Edelman right they knew right away the
backs were out of the equation yeah so
but that's one thing but we got to start
giving a defensive player in this and
the Super Bowl and MVP awards you know
that there wasn't a single player on the
Patriots defense that received a single
vote which is the redonkulous that's
ridiculous yes that just tells you the
world we're in I'm surprised Eva's still
gonna get it I really when the game was
gonna voted for Dante Hightower or
Stephon Gilmore Gilmore is the most
egregious when I think because he had
the closing interception he had so many
great plays that passing offense was
reduced to nothing yeah you know I
listed a Hightower's a little deep in
there like I wouldn't have seen it right
you're a I guess well you gotta have
somebody pointed out and and I think
they did point it out in a telecast
enough you know said some things but
guys like them get washed out of it you
know so Michael Bennett what's the
change the Heisman the MVP it's all just
become the same award who's the best
quarterback on the best team that's
that's the most valuable player in
football if he didn't throw for 300
who's another player that that has some
good statistics yeah yeah right it just
goes down the line so it's not because
of favoritism it's because the media
doesn't know what they're watching and
they're scared so what they do is they
go
this a lot of people will do this and I
can hide behind this yeah well you know
not only that it's just like the Hall of
Fame I wouldn't be a voter for the Pro
Football Hall of Fame or why would you
be in the hut oh I want to be a voter
for the writers Hall of Fame you know
because you know I've heard this Chris
takes so many times come on I want to
know now that I know that you've been
workshopping no yeah yeah we always do
it we do it yeah I know just go come
come on we speak frankly technically we
know more about writing than a lot of
them know about football watching
football strictly as a as a fan it's
like a Rick and Morty epic deep board
thing was really cool I think the
Patriots are like the epitome of that
really I mean you think about tuck rule
you think stupid-ass Darrell Bevell and
not running Marshall give me another one
there's one more let's jump cemetery
whoa just think of the catch damn that's
another REO Manningham yeah well those
two plays they could have won both games
here here's one yeah go how about the
Carolina Panthers tie the game all the
kick the kick you know kicks out of
bounds it's like he kicked away out
about yeah I mean what they are really
excited my friend Alex had to mean he's
a Patriots fan he said that Patriots
Rams Super Bowl was proof that the
Saints Rams finish was a glitch in the
matrix that it wasn't supposed to happen
this way and like the world's going and
something got thrown off kilter right
like one little thing and the butterfly
effect ruined the Super Bowl well you
know mother my other little thing I
wrote down I can read them all yeah we
got Heat Christopher did a great job of
some of them but I was watching the year
we won the Super Bowl my first one when
I was the MVP and I knew who was playing
in the AFC Championship game putting it
on the wall and I remember sitting there
are going in the training room to tape
something on my hand I had a cut on my
hand before I miss Browns or some watch
of John Elway in the drive and I see
that they win and I went oh good I'm
glad Denver win if we went today I'd
rather play Denver than the Cleveland
Browns
because the Cleveland Browns were
getting like you guys room and yeah
Cleveland Browns were big good corners
you know I'd have been that have been a
headache so thank God Denver pulled it
out
22:25 the drive you know the drive it's
a it lives forever but it wasn't a Super
Bowl they lost the Super Bowl yeah if
they get there and win it's like the
Minnesota miracle
sniffing digs catch that touchdown and
it will knit will be one of the greatest
playoff moments of all time they got
their ass kicked the next week yeah
first thing for Patriots offense Rams
defense Sims writes Chris writes
Christopher writes I'm getting it right
Patriots run f Wham
right off the bat right yeah right what
does that mean to you it means right
away they were just going let's take
advantage of the Rams being psycho and
ready to go up field and Sue and Donnell
they're gonna ruin the play let him fly
up swam and when F Wham is the full-back
now who's like not right in front of the
tailback he's offset a little bit and
they were gonna wham the three technique
the three technique which was sooo on
this play he's on the outside shoulder
of the right guard the guard is
basically gonna like act like he's in a
block him and then let him go and Susan
around feel me oh I got him and also he
hold back on the side and fullback and
the Patriots busted up a run right up
the middle right on with that right two
plays I did before the game in an
illustration yeah what they were f wham
wam right and I did the house why'd you
yeah the three places you saw that so
many times nice nose yeah how about that
though I bailed with the two plays I
picked out for their offense and they
were big all right you gotta say this
yeah when Devlin hits ooh oh my god he
hit like he months ago what was that cuz
he got hit back I mean Devlin who is to
me the best blocking tight in the back
in the NFL right really he hit Donald
sued some of them sometimes and I mean
he didn't move an inch that's incredible
yeah that's pretty good on the
interception you know I don't know why
Brady was so casual they didn't show
man-to-man Peters was on 34 before
motion right back in the backfield which
showed it was zone is what I was saying
there Peters was matched up with
Birkhead which you know his zone they're
not gonna go L best corner take on the
backup tailback here man-to-man and man
to cut man coverage so he knew it was
zone I think we'll call Brady by
surprise and dad saw it as just
I just don't think he thought nickel
Roby Coleman was gonna buzz out there so
aggressively the wave started as motion
kind of did exactly right so I think
Brady saw the look and he just thought
well I'm gonna keep my eyes down field
just to keep everybody where they are
and then I'll come over and throw it and
they called Roby Coleman just said no
I'm gonna get underneath one other cool
thing that you had a lot in your notes
is Wade Phillips really did coaches
awesome and you wrote oh right here I
love how the Rams are having their
defensive ends like hitting the running
backs in the passing game there's a
patriot ship that some page that's what
we always talking about what would Bill
Belichick do right wwbd right and there
you go Wade Phillips goes okay oh I'm
gonna take some [ __ ] every time I see
James White flare out Dante Fowler screw
Russian Brady go knock him down if we're
not gonna get there in two and a half is
like a split you know a yard away from
the tackle knock him before you go all
those little things make a difference in
this that would happen on the sack
fumble to the sack fumble oh yeah all
day bed all day
they have three-man rush it was a
three-man rush they did jam Groff away
yes and it was a three-man rush but but
you know go ahead we're gonna say
anything else no no Tom Brady stood dear
looked everywhere forever right they you
know what happens when you like that as
a quarterback
you're not gonna spot anybody cuz you're
to like you know and he couldn't figure
out there I think somebody was open I
can't remember the play exactly there
was an incoming wide open whatever but
he couldn't see and and they were lucky
to get that but that was cool they did
that didn't you think yeah he ends and
do that I mean you've always something
we we have yelled out like yeah seams do
this more I think we're gonna see it I
think what that was really great that
you brought that up Wade Phillips he's
he's gonna do that the rest of his
career I'm gonna use that oh absolutely
after what he did that game there were
places for a coach like way though to be
able to change weight you know what when
I could leave here today I am gonna text
him that's awesome because he is honest
and I will he's one of the greatest
people you'll ever meet
I mean I was like oh my god and DeMarcus
Ware when they won the Super Bowl
against the Carolina Panthers yeah the
first week I said DeMarcus you know
Wade's the new head coach he goes
nudee coordinator the way he talked
about Wade the connection with way to
the players was like nothing he'd ever
been around yeah he goes he can tell us
the exact same thing that we've heard
but man when he says it it just is
better and it just makes us play better
and they practice you know their
practices in Denver with that defense
man man I don't care if the who was over
on offense man they intercepted
everything I'm grant was great he loved
them you're gonna say though about the
you said the backs are gonna do this
forever it's gonna be Chris there you
were about to say Christopher I came
there I couldn't sometimes they were
doing things I couldn't figure out what
they were doing on defense all I know is
the coverage was all over everything
right right I just like what are they
trying to do and I said you know I don't
have time I'm just gonna mix well yeah
Yeah right right
you were very impressed with the Rams
she said Rams d flying all over the
field Patriots are having a hard time
pulling guards because the Rams are so
explosive and they stopped doing it they
stop pulling guards cuz they realize
like we always talk about swine New
England's amazing they said you know
what every time we pull a guard there is
are poles aaron donald just follows them
right down the line and makes the tackle
and they stop doing and then early in
yeah they knew drew out a 21 personnel
here right what were you trying to show
well I was just trying to show that let
me just see here oh I was just trying to
show what they were doing with their 21
personnel they were getting in 21
personnel or even 22 personnel at the
end of the game two backs to tighten
down why we're saying right and getting
in you know in some positions where they
were putting the receivers inside right
and like you showed your outside right
and that's how they did a good job of
fingering out oh is a man or is its own
yeah tells you right away and now and
now they know all its zone this is how
we'll get Edelman inside on the middle
linebacker who's playing zone that's how
they felt not all that dry you go Dan
why is the middle linebacker covering
Julian Edelman he's not he's playing his
own
I don't know England's cleared it all
out to make it look like it that's why I
didn't think McVeigh did on offense
enough not like he was an 11 personnel
the entire game and didn't spread it out
and didn't mix it up to try and find
some of those men that's what everybody
said why would you have a line back
cover Elliman oh you yeah they weren't
meaning to do that they were getting
into a job by the patriot no I mean come
on no I'm kind of making fun of the
people who talk about it
oh yes yes do you think they really
wanted the linebacker on Edelman in the
middle no it tells you it was something
that big thing is they got the extra
linebacker on the field it took a little
the speed away from the Rams and a few
of the times and the Rams got in these
formations and they spread the field and
they had their base defense on they're
going oh wait wait hold on what are our
rules here wait you know a q bomb you
got to go out there and cover Devlin all
the way out there and also there was
communication that way too
yeah and you said when it comes to man a
man that it should have been more Peters
on Edelman than Talib you say - leaves
lost some of us quick I do i yeah he's
definitely too big listen he's at the
point of his career where it's going
downwards he's still a really good
football player I do think and again I
give Wade credit here after Aqib Talib
got toasted twice in the first half they
put Marcus Peters on Edelman from that
point on and I thought he did a much
better job I mean I really did but yeah
it was it was a tough matchup for him I
do think Peters matched up better with
Edelman Roby Coleman played him a couple
times do you you love that the Patriots
did some self scouting all the playoffs
Edelman was doing deep crossers and then
the Super Ball you look like a deep
crosser we got to keep to leave early
twice I mean write a big play looked
like it was gonna run across and they're
saying all on film and practice all week
all we did is I chased these damn
crossers across the field oh he came out
oh no that's that's really what happened
to them a few times really two big ones
to two two times really big plays that's
how I know fell games get decided yeah
do you have to make them count
well that it goes back to what I said
earlier that Edelman everything he did
was kind of like it was well designed
well thought out and really and he took
advantage of all those thoughts right
that made it happen it's the number one
issue with our show and Sims evaluations
excuse me
Christopher's evaluation yeah is that
the rest of the world doesn't look at
scheme they look at it as like a
non-factor and for Christopher it's it
takes like notches down that in your
mind
when you're schemed for you're supposed
to have numbers like that you're
supposed to execute that it's not you
doing it is not a bonus I'm not gonna
sit here and go oh my gosh julian
edelman so amazing he came in motion and
Brady said set hut
and he ran off the butt of Gronk and he
ran straight and Brady threw in the ball
right in his chest and we go oh my gosh
this Julian Edelman so my question we
hop her home oh my god if they used
chris hogan the way they did element
wouldíve he he would not maximize it no
way no medal okay so there's a little
bit differently i'm Edelman's the guy
they realized that so they make a lot of
the plays what is he doing that lets say
a Hogan wouldn't've dude well he just
he's a quicker more explosive athlete no
question that's it right he's faster
quicker more power he's crafty too you
know he's really understands how he's
being played and how to play the
coverage off of the play he's about to
run you think about the big play where
he catches right up the middle that
quick step right okay
there they got a perfect defense called
Marcus Peters is travelling across he
jumps outside cuz he knows all right I
guess those guys in them and what really
happened is Dante Fowler fire zone he
dropped out he should have been where
Edelman caught the ball but what
happened is Gronkowski crossed his face
and he took a few steps and took the
cheese and went with Gronkowski now
Peters looks like he's getting beat when
he's really supposed to have help inside
there in that scenario but that's what
great coaching does cuz the coach Josh
McDaniels goes down well if this
linebacker of this defense end hey drop
back into coverage and do this look to
us you know they're not used to this and
they're gonna see Rob Gronkowski who we
throw the ball to a lot and they'll take
the cheese and I just open it up and
that's that's what they're gonna exactly
right I mean that was an old play deer
and they just used it a different way it
was really close I mean it was almost
like it was your FFA no just yeah it was
just a shallow cross and he looks like
he's gonna kind of run something out and
then he comes right up yeah who did that
the Cowboys started with Norv Turner
right up for all it Jay Novacek and
moose Johnson yeah it was that play 25f
angles nobody calls what they called it
yeah sometimes 524 you kept going about
like waxing poetic about wait Rams
defense this game plan is great they're
changing looks a few curveballs doing
the little things like Bill Belichick
Bill Belichick de hit in the slot wide
receiver zone looks like man and they
doubled Gronk great job wait you're
proud of wait it sounds like I mean
defending this damn offense are you
kidding me I mean this offense it's the
one of the greatest design run games in
the history of the sport could await
Philips ever get an MVP in a Super Bowl
did I ever do something like you know
that's a good question yeah and no
they're not gonna give it to the coaches
but it wouldn't hurt you do something
into that effect right one system
whatever then right and you know what a
game coaching deserve to be an MVP but
you know what no because nobody could
understand that they won't and what if a
punter would kill it cuz a lot of people
were talking to her the game that Johnny
Hecker could have gotten it how would
you have thought about that I would have
felt cheated as an American don't
evaluate kickers just don't I don't
that's right I mean if you throw maybe
like three trick you know trick play
passes okay maybe that's all hey during
a pregame I showed all of his stuff it
was hilarious yeah pump fakes thrown a
deep rollout pass got a pretty good arm
really good one to be a quarterback at
college they said you know we you're
okay but you're gonna put right yeah I
guess that worked out pretty well yeah I
would say so it's like being a lefty
pitcher Wade deserves a lot of credit
because that's a lot to handle that
offense and they have a 18 year rolodex
of Josh McDaniels and Brady that you
have to worry about and they were all
over it I mean think about them when
they played AFC championship game the
year Denver went and won the Super Bowl
right they really confused Brady that
game too yes they did went against Wade
went against all of his tendencies that
day yeah and the Patriots admitted
afterwards
well they fooled us early right well it
took him too long to get into the game
so all of this brings us to the only
touchdown drive of the game so I'm gonna
let you kind of look at your notes and I
know that you've seen this and take us
through the same formation and the same
play they ran about three times in a row
many times in a row my question for you
is what did they see
earlier in
right to go let's do this three times go
they ran it in the first half and Brady
misread it and what's the play called
Hoss why'd you write horse because it
means hitch on the outside H oh I seen
the two inside receivers go up the seams
and the two hitches and the two inside
see and why Duke is his Edelman he's in
the third receiver on one side three and
two right he goes in and decides either
to hook it up or shake the linebacker
whoever's in there covered him and get
away so you got some good options in a
fellow field they ran in the first half
Edelman was wide open uncovered right
but Brady tried the seamed and almost
ended up being an interception through
the second Drive of the game second
drive the game and it was like play
through the seam to the left it was
almost got intercepted it was right yeah
so no dad's right about that exactly and
so they probably went looked at the look
through the little monitor saw that it
was actually their drive started with
the fake play-action
Gronkowski is right play man-to-man and
he sheds them right and then runs down
because they make it look like a run
that's how that starts on the linebacker
right that's a backyard football no it's
another made-up play right it's a drive
starter it's a drive starter helped the
quarterback get us moving get it first
down out we're confident out were
rolling they were always levered just
for that like I guarantee that was a
double call like if we don't have man
then we can't run it but we know it's
man and now a cue bombs got a guard
Gronkowski and worried about the running
game Gronk's gonna make it look like the
run and then throw them and then go down
the field for a pass it's a truly great
way to start the truck great way to
start the drive then it starts then they
put in 22 personnel it's two backs to
tight ends only Edelman's the only so in
your mind they realized that when we go
into this it forces the rams to go base
and there's a few matchups up there that
we really think we can win and I bet you
it simplified them too to where they
have you a feel to go they only play
these two or three defenses and we trust
with this play that we put in our
offense pretty early on and OTAs that
Brady will read the play correctly and
make the appropriate decision with the
two or three coverages they play against
it and the
rule was basically this you get two deep
safeties julian edelman work the middle
linebacker on the Jew crowd he's got a
man away go he could stop if did
everything the bread seed parts he's
gonna sit over the ball at six yards and
show his hands and Tom's gonna put it on
him if he gets matched and the guy tries
to cut him from crossing he's gonna push
the guy act like he's gonna run across
and then come back out if the guys too
aggressive and tries to come right at
him
he's gonna kind of stutter and then go
across his face and you know look at
that little shallow cross so it's all
the same play but it's Edelman has to
read it correctly when it's a linebacker
each time most of the times when it goes
in them it's gonna be a lot better deeps
yes it's gonna be linebacker but then
when they play single safety or do
something like that I got the seam now
he's gonna go well the middle of the
fields crowded I'm not gonna throw to
that and now let me see the hitch on the
outside over the seam and I have the
plays here if anybody wants to look at
him either way he throws the first one
to Edelman over the Middle's too deep
second one they run the play okay greedy
three deep three deep and I'm gonna and
he gets and he goes okay wait all right
there I'm gonna get to it just so I can
really talk to it real and he goes okay
wait I'm gonna throw it and he goes I
got Rex Burkhead on a corner here and
I'm afraid the corners gonna try to
steal the seam at zone coverage got a
read number two which is the seam and
I'm just gonna throw it out there and he
hits it hits Rex Burkhead so they get
like six or seven hitch they come back
they run in this getting the same
formation exactly the same once again
for whatever reason the Rams get a
little confused on how they want to line
up and do it on this play and Brady goes
it because they just got led up to
receptions in a row James covered his
right so they went to deep three then
man-to-man right and they got a little
confused the third time all three for
whatever reason and then that was where
Brady just said oh they're a little
confused the safeties away from
Gronkowski here and I'm gonna take Gronk
one-on-one up the seam and what a catch
and what a catch and really first things
Isis Esaias eyes is a skill and I don't
know it's e to me I mean this is like
josh mcdaniels that's about your big
balls by Josh well you know it is and
you know - you always got to be alert
once it gets inside the 40 yard line 30
yard
whatever one of the patrons gonna do
they're gonna run a seam and try to
score I mean my god they lead the world
and throw on that seam pass to tight
ends yes running bags whatever it is and
that would be my first alert always
always talked about it and there was and
they got Cory Littleton I think on a
man-to-man yeah so you know Brady could
have thrown it like he did I think it
was Mark Barron on that one was it mark
barely get out there think so yeah yeah
well he thought the way he did he could
have thrown it on a line drive which
most the time he usually line drives the
ball so if the guy turns it's too late
but he lobbed it soft and Grunk you know
he just went for the safe catch he just
he wanted to make sure he caught it not
otherwise I think he just caught it with
his hands and tried to score no doubt
what he bodied it and just man cradled
it and it was you know he took him to
the ground it was still moving a little
but he caught it yeah what did this tell
you about Josh those three plays three
plays he made them all look different to
a degree okay the first one he just
lined up empty backfield Brady's in the
backfield okay okay here it is
next time same play Tom but we're gonna
start the back in the backfield with you
and motion him out to the left and then
he threw direction Burkett he said Oh
zone coverage I'm gonna just throw it
out there he's got free access to him
next time he does the same thing as he
does the first play because the
formation to the left - where Edelman's
over there and then motions them across
- then get back to exactly the way the
first play looked where he hit element
making them think now they're they're
going and I could show it to you here
right now we're all of a sudden they're
going away you got em and safety do here
at all that I've said all year right
this is what McVeigh does off of the
speed sweep that they have 15 plays that
they run off of the same look right but
you're telling me that the Super Bowl
was decided on Josh McDaniels out
McVeigh McVeigh that's how dare you well
you can't say no no you don't ever well
I like the statement right but Josh
McDaniels has been doing it for a lot
more he has you're going to say
McDaniels is the original McVeigh
man come on he doesn't have a system it
just keeps rolling it's just it's a good
example I did a giant game with the
Patriots the Patriots have Gronk out to
starting offensive linemen no wide
receivers
and I talked to Josh every week before I
do the game and I said you know Josh you
know boy he goes all this is gonna be
grateful you know I just we got to come
up a lot you know to get five yards go
take a lot we and he was so excited yeah
he was truly excited that they didn't
have all these guys cuz he wanted to see
B can manipulate and do everything and
win the game and you know what happened
they beat the Giants yeah it got a
little lucky at the end Brady threw a
pass down the middle it was dropped by
the safety easy interception he drops it
and of course what happens you give him
another second chance
they go down score and win the game yeah
but that's him and my son of course
knows he more than ever than I do
because he worked up there I guess you
told hate farm in Denver play for me
dimly seen it firsthand yeah yeah he's
amazing but in all seriousness
do you remember and you're 15 your
career your offensive coordinator
calling the same play three times in a
row well we were different yeah we would
come on you watch this play we always I
mean it's like my son Matt goes damn all
you through where seems 20-yard in cuts
in 20 yard out cuts yeah yeah the backs
weren't part of what you did or whatever
we would repeat plays constantly right
but three in a row like that no not
three in a row like that no not three I
find it fascinating weed the best double
ups I ever beat Rock three times in a
row we were back when the Dallas 10-yard
line
Ernie start nor you would remember him
big ol guy where he we call a play
that's we're gonna block it up it's
gonna be an all-out blitz if it's not an
all-out blitz I'm screwed I go throw it
away well it's an all-out blitz perfect
so I throw the out Catalano mania for 10
or 12 yards we call the same play again
and I'm going what the hell this is
stupid first down they're not going to
blitz I get up under there they all out
blitz I throw another out cut for about
15 the second time so the game is over
we win and I get on the bus and Parcells
we're talking I said what made y'all
call that same play twice he goes I knew
that coach over there was pissed and I
knew him I know how he is I knew he'd do
it again just to show what and I just go
wow I said that was pretty cool that's
know in the coach right knowing the
coach
no one is personality and everything and
what they're gonna do that's like when
you see like poker like legends and
they're like you're not playing the
cards you know that other person you're
playing the other person yeah it's the
day and age where it's I got all these
plays I got a show all my tricks all my
tricks that's where I thought of as cool
and really it brought me back to the
Rams Patriots the first time because the
Patriots when they played the Rams the
first time ever they knew going into
that game Mike Martz never called the
same play twice so once you saw it erase
it from your memory he's going to move
on and go to something new yeah and I
just he wanted to show you you were Rams
Patriots I just thought it was funny
yeah they'd show Monda you know they
their play callers they're complete
designers they can't help but sometimes
I worked on these plays all week we
wrapped it I got to do it I want to do
it this is cool I can you see them
dotted you ever see him they Gore shot
it right that that's that's typical or
moving on yeah yeah you're saying yeah
something new yeah yeah but I don't know
there's something about showing the same
thing with variation that I find oh yeah
well it's it's easy for the players the
other thing is just that year when they
played right the Patriots defense that's
when the Patriots won their first Super
Bowl Bill Belichick second year they
blitz relentlessly right and what they
do in the Super Bowl didn't blitz it I
didn't do anything I did the old let's
hit them and do all this know blitzing
right make them earn it and yeah they
pulled one out I'm so happy that you
came in it's a little bit sad that it's
becoming because it's our last I was
gonna be about a twenty minutes show two
hours at least
commercials my afternoon nap time right
here
Jeff fun though yeah it was great it
really was great it was great you're the
man Christopher I'm sad you're leaving
here but as it was great the fact did
you get to talk so much is really the
best thing of all feel like therapy you
know it is yeah I do radio shows all
week you know why because it's therapy
yeah call me last night he wanted to
have the pot I had a literally at 9:45
say hey could you shut up and save it
for the podcast
I'll call you next Wednesday I'll be
ready for sim peace out homey or Sims
yeah there's no peace out homies from me
for fender good evening everybody and
for the lef koe man we will holla holla
holla at you tomorrow hit us up in
Calverton you normally do for the
mailbag we're gonna collect them get
them ready mailbag and we're doing one
last as crazy as you want you can't edit
me too much you know all this you're
being cool all that stuff you got about
two more years and it's over you think
so
timeout of loco and we'll see you next
time on the podcast
you